[Music]
a new Ghostbusters movie is coming in
2020 surprise everybody it's set in the
same world as the original movies and
takes place in present-day Entertainment
Weekly just broke this story Jason
Reitman will direct and co-write his
father directed the original movies at
this time we don't know the cast or
whether the original actors will return
but what we do know is that there's a
lot of opinions so we're gonna decide if
we're okay with this and Who am I gonna
call Jermaine Lucy air hello who who
better who better but I don't know maybe
somebody who likes goes but not kidding
are you in I'm so in and I just still
can't believe that this is a thing I
mean it has now been when we're filming
this like 24 hours yeah and like it's
just happening so quickly we've got then
we got the announcement we got the
teaser trailer already like 18 months
I'm in for it I like the idea of Jason
Reitman doing it I really like his
movies obviously like you know that's
like a passing of the torch kind of
feeling because his father yeah his
father that's not always a recipe for
success obviously but I like him and I
like the idea of him doing it he said in
his interview was W that he thinks of
himself as the first Ghostbusters fan
because he was on set when they were
shooting it yeah so before the movie
came out and people saw it like the
summer of 84 they he was a fan he knew
about it and then he appears at the
beginning of the second one to his right
as a little annoying kid that's really
funny I was just watching this interview
with him to where he was like I had he
had like one of the the guns from the
set and he was like oh I completely
ruined it because I just like my dad
would just let me play with it and use
it for my halloween costume I just sold
it financed this movie but he's also
said like throughout the years I would
never I wouldn't want to do it yeah and
then suddenly I guess an idea came up
that he couldn't resist anything like I
guess I mean he's obviously an amazing
filmmaker I mean he made it just this
year or last year now new year forgot
about that
he made Tully and the front-runner
mm-hmm but in the past teams made thank
you for smoking jus know he's been
nominated for Oscars like he makes great
movies they just never makes any hits
and I think the back to back of Tully in
the front-runner with service you know
Charlize Theron and Hugh Jackman not
doing well I think he probably was like
nothing Ghostbusters ideals new thing
with yeah I can definitely get that
movie made and if this movie's a big hit
then he can go back to
making all his crazy small movies yeah
it's like I need a hip I need a hit I
think that's what it feels like to me
but it's also serendipitous and perfect
because that he's been around it he
understands it if anybody can get the
original guys to come back well just
Bill Murray because obviously Ernie
Hudson and Dana Corbett sitting by their
phone all oh yeah because they
immediately were tweeting about it which
makes me think that they're gonna show
up or be involved in some way so you
can't if they're sold if you're there so
live it's the force awakens if they're
still alive you bring them back like
just for a little bit you didn't have to
be in the movie the whole time yeah you
know but but how I mean it's been like
it's gonna be like 30 years yes almost
40 years actually and it's like what are
these guys been doing and the trailer
you just showed it's like who's in that
barn
like why is the ecto-1 like out of
Manhattan in a barn like has it been
used I have no idea it's funny well I
feel like every episode we do we end up
comparing something just super horse but
it does kind of feel like it's gonna be
like a force awakens thing where that
goes passing the torch and then these
guys are gonna show up throughout the
way for like advice and help at
somewhere or yeah we're explain to them
how it's done I mean they're used to the
rumor is that I think was a Hollywood
Reporter said right was looking to cast
two teenage boys and two teenage girls
for the leads which you assume would be
the new Ghostbusters I could do other
movies but yeah like there's always this
idea I think it was like max landis
whose father John Landis maybe like
American Werewolf in London put on
Twitter years ago that like you do like
Seth Rogen and Jonah Hill and sort of
like those like super bad job apps tell
people and they are the new Ghostbusters
that get the you know torch pass to them
I think it's a little past that time now
where those guys are in there you can
late 30s early 40s yeah
so you do younger kids but the idea of
you know thank men and those guys coming
back and explaining what ghost busting
is about to a younger generation yeah
really kind of legitimized it
yeah and I'm hoping I would love to see
Rick Moranis
yeah please do much I know but I just
want him there him in an teapots you
kind of have to hang around you yeah you
don't really I mean William Atherton
there's so many great people you could
bring back if you had and yeah I mean
Rick Moranis
is crucial Sigourney obviously you know
everybody's around except for
Harold Ramis you know just after he
co-wrote the movies with Dan Aykroyd so
so he's a huge loss as Egon but uh you
know they pay tribute to him in that
Paul Feig movie so there's ways around
that yeah I'm wondering if maybe we'll
get like his child or something in the
movie kind of legacy kind of thing I
mean after like 40 years and we do know
that there is squirting Weaver's kid
that's right that's right talking about
the cast cuz we were talking about Jason
right knows movies and he's done Tully
and Juno and young adult all with female
leads and I think the assumption at
first for people was like oh this is
gonna be for dudes but it's like no this
is it seems like it's gonna be couldn't
make them you can't couldn't make this
movie for dudes anymore though that eras
done yeah and like and but maybe I think
maybe the last movie was maybe people
weren't ready for a real movie before a
female which is crazy you know but yeah
that kind of that movie is I think it's
a funny movie the Paul Feig movie and
yeah it just didn't do well people
didn't connect with it and whether that
was the humor or it can't be that cuz
they're all awesome like they're so I
like that movie for what it was I
thought Kate McKinnon was great I think
it's a special time where we won't get
like her in a sequel at some point or I
wish there was some people don't mean a
lot of people haven't rewatched that
movie but that movie ends with an end
credits scene where they mentioned the
word Zul which is the bad guy from the
first ghostbusters so that was like
their way of like oh we're going to sort
of work to maybe this movie you know so
I think they might be in the same
universe I think reitman saying that now
because it's the right thing to say
yeah but you can't have a video shelf or
what am I aging myself a video shelf you
don't have a Netflix queue that says
ghostbusters ghostbusters to
ghostbusters answer the call and then
Ghostbusters 2020 big what does answer
the call why is that here on this like
box set you know I think they have to
figure out a way to get it in but as of
right now he says that it is not related
and this one is a direct sequel to
ghostbusters 2 alright so final thoughts
are you okay with this
absolutely I'm more than okay I am ready
to go the fact that it's summer 2020 and
not summer 2022 or something yeah it'd
be incredibly excited we're a year and a
half out I'm okay
this show always hypes me for things
more than I already was I was like okay
yeah this is cool let's talk about it
now I'm like yes I am very okay with
this give it to me now proton perks
yeah do it Slimer yeah oh yeah at all do
it okay well guys let me know what you
think are you excited for a new
Ghostbusters what he most excited to see
what do you want to see out of the movie
I'm a - Carson and Jermaine where can we
see you you can spy my work on io9.com
and Twitter Instagram everything like
that at Jermaine was here thanks for
coming in there thank you and we're okay
with it
[Music]